hey guys remember when you were a kid
and you'd always imagine what you were
gonna be when you grew up
dear God one day please make me white
thank you it was a great feeling
wasn't it I mean your whole life was
ahead of you when I grow up I'm gonna be
a scientist discover something or maybe
even President of the United States
you're doing a great job American maybe
even an astronomer loves me and then we
grow up and we realize that growing up
sucks dick so did I get the part no if
you're not chasing your dreams right now
stop as far as we know we live once so
why waste this lifetime pursuing
something that's not truly in your heart
do what you believe you're meant to do
dude why are you wearing that duh I'm a
space princess dreams come true purrs
you know what I mean if you're sitting
at home right now and you're unhappy
with your life change it I know it's
easier said than done
I only decided to pursue my real dream
once my younger sister passed away and I
was a wake-up call so take it from
someone who's witnessed that we all die
but not all of us live so live
motherfucker with stay off and Gotha
what I grew up I want to be a scientist
but I grow up I'm going to be a
scientist or or maybe even President of
the United States
let's try another
[Applause]